PAUL YOUNG: Welcome
to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We host webinars every Tuesday.
My name is Paul
Young and today we'll
be talking about power
innovation for SAP
with Google Cloud.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform.
Today we have Googlers, SAP-ers,
and customers on standby
to answer them, so ask away.
So let's get started.
As discussed, Paul Young and
I'm the go-to-market director
for SAP Google Cloud.
You'll hear plenty
from me, so let's move
on to the people that matter.
Next to me here is
Isabell Petzelt,
global vice president of SAP
Cloud Platform, go-to-market.
How do you even fit
that on a business card?
I want to ask.
We'll just move on from there.
Extra weight business
cards for your job titles.
Subject of the
day, first of all,
is SAP Google Cloud partnership.
Especially around SAP Cloud
Platform but in general, too.
Secondly, we have a customer
perspective with METRO.
Just great, Axel
Koss from METRO will
be talking about their
deployment and the decision
criteria and how we do it.
Just fantastic content.
And then lastly, we'll have
a conversation about running
SAP on Google Cloud.
And the things we're
doing to make Google Cloud
the best place
possible to run SAP.
And, at the end of
that, hopefully we'll
have time to fit in some
questions and answers as well.
So all that said, let's
get started with topic one.
Welcome, Isabell.
ISABELL PETZELT:
Thank you, Paul.
PAUL YOUNG: So do you
want to introduce yourself
to the people, won't you?
ISABELL PETZELT: Absolutely.
Isabell Petzelt. I run the
global centers of expertise
for SAP Cloud Platform.
That's why the name's so along.
So I work a lot with
customers around the globe
in helping them transition
their core enterprise
application into the cloud.
PAUL YOUNG: Great.
Thank you for coming along.
And you're a long-time
SAP person, right?
ISABELL PETZELT:
[? 60 ?] plus years.
Still running strong.
PAUL YOUNG: That's always good.
So what's top of mind?
What's the challenges that
actually your customers
have right now?
ISABELL PETZELT: Right.
So what customers are really
challenged about today
is fundamentally different
than what happened
in the last few decades.
And SAP traditionally
was focused on really
about standardizing, optimizing
core business processes.
But today customers
are really forced
to innovate and
differentiate themselves
with disruptive business models,
with complete new customer
experiences.
Also, giving employees
more purpose in their work,
where they leverage a lot
of technologies and data
to really solve
those challenges.
And what we see in the most
successful companies-- what
they are doing-- they are
adopting new technologies
and leveraging
data very quickly.
And that is what is delivering
really game-changing outcomes
for them.
Because first, they achieve
a step change in productivity
by applying technologies
like machine learning,
like artificial intelligence
to those core business
processes to automate them
to make them more efficient.
Second, they also redefine
the customer experience
because it's not
only about anymore
responding to customer needs.
It is about predicting what
customers want and create
that satisfaction before
the customers even know it.
And third, it's really about
transforming their employee
engagement.
Because employees want to
have more purpose from work.
They automate certain tasks
so employees can really
focus on higher
level value-adding
activities and tasks to really
move the company forward.
And that is what we
really talk about
and what we mean with
intelligent enterprise
because customers today
are hungry for innovation,
to differentiate themselves.
PAUL YOUNG: All right.
Again, I hear the intelligent
enterprise conversation a lot.
And I think that's a
really powerful way
to explain it, right?
So it's not just about
analytics, a certain one thing.
It is about that complete
package for the customer.
Very cool.
So what's SAP doing to deliver
against those challenges?
Great idea.
What do we do to fix it?
ISABELL PETZELT: Exactly.
Great idea.
So I said, customers are
really forced to differentiate.
But they want to build that
innovation on a solid trusted
environment that, on
the one hand side,
gives them the flexibility but
at the other hand side, still
has that robustness and security
to run their core applications.
Because that is what customers
love and trust about SAP--
running that solid core.
And that is where also SAP
has that process heritage.
But now customers really want
to build new functionality
on top of those core processes
to really differentiate
themselves.
Look what happened last
week with Cyber Monday,
where everyone went crazy
here in US shopping,
where retailers
actually launched
a very specific set
of functionality
on their digital platforms
to create a new customer
experience, to launch
specific promotions,
to engage differently with
customers to boost up sales.
You don't want to build those
extensions that only are there
for a week or two into your
core business applications.
You want to build them
side-by-side on a platform also
utilizing latest technologies--
like machine learning
and so on--
to create that experience.
And that is what SAP both
delivers-- on the one hand
side, solid packaged
applications
for the core business
processes and a platform
to deliver and build
those innovations on top,
and everything in a
single environment.
PAUL YOUNG: So I spent a long
time as a customer of SAP,
actually running SAP systems.
I spent a long time with SAP.
I'll tell you, the point where
it came over to Google Cloud,
the thing that amazed me
was, I think, day three.
I walked in a room
where there were
20 engineers working on a
single joint project, right?
Amazing alignment and investment
between Google and SAP
to deliver something
that's much more than just,
hey, you can run SAP on
Google Cloud hardware.
So do you want to talk quickly
on your perspective on how
Google Cloud and SAP
are working together
to take this far beyond just
another place you can run,
execute Cloud.
ISABELL PETZELT: Absolutely.
I think that the
partnership between Google
is as fundamental
in a game changer
because together we are helping
our customers in their mission
to succeed in the
digital transformation.
Because I think there are
two fundamental things
that the teams have delivered.
First, they really
created, as you just
said, a fantastic place to
run SAP applications on top
of Google Cloud.
But really optimizing SAP
apps to run on Google Cloud.
But also optimized Google
Cloud to run as apps.
So those engineering
initiatives are
happening on both sides for the
maximum efficiency and scale.
So look what we've done with
the virtual machines for HANA,
starting with a few terabytes.
And now you can deploy
16, 18 terabytes
at the snap of a finger.
So that was really the one
piece to create the best
place to run SAP applications.
But what is even
more game changing,
as we spoke before--
customers want
to build new functionality.
They want to use
latest technology.
And that is why that move--
having SAP Cloud Platform
run on Google Cloud--
was a fundamental game changer
because now customers can
consume cutting-edge
technologies from Google--
be it machine learning,
be it TensorFlow models--
and really apply and infuse them
into the core processes of SAP
in building those
differentiating innovations
right out of the box.
So we do all the
plumbing for them.
They can really focus on
building the innovation.
And that is what really builds
those intelligent enterprises.
PAUL YOUNG: It's incredibly cool
if you follow through as well.
I think this development
where Google fits in the world
is that, if you look at sort
of what we're looking at,
we're also providing data sets.
I'm here with the stuff
just Cloud for marketing
where we have the
live analysis of what
our customers'
advertised this morning.
Are people responding to it?
The ability to,
through Cloud Platform,
to join that through and just
power at a level of granularity
and a level of detail and a
level of execution that's just
never been achieved before.
That's much, much
more than just a place
to run SAP in the Cloud.
ISABELL PETZELT: Exactly
PAUL YOUNG: Very cool.
So your favorite
subject, Cloud Platform,
obviously fits into this.
Give us the drill.
How does Cloud Platform
bind all of this together?
ISABELL PETZELT: Absolutely.
Cloud Platform is
almost the glue
that's the centerpiece of--
PAUL YOUNG: Not that
you're biased about it.
ISABELL PETZELT: No.
Because customers really,
on the one hand side,
they need those
business services.
They need those processes.
And they need the innovation or
the infrastructure technology
services from Google Cloud
to really extend their core
processes in the
SAP applications
with those technologies and
really combine, as I just said,
transactional data
with other sources
that come from Google,
from wherever in the world,
to really change the
customer experience
and really deliver those
disruptive business models.
But they want to do that
on a platform in parallel
to their core systems.
So Cloud Platform almost
becomes the bridge
between their packaged apps
and their innovation platform,
the bridge between on-premise
and cloud application,
because it's a stepwise
move, because customers
are moving massive enterprise
workloads into the Cloud.
And they want to do
that at their own pace.
And that is exactly what SAP
Cloud Platform gives them.
It's really the innovation
layer in the cloud
to build intelligent
enterprise applications.
And that is what is
really the game changer
in the partnership--
that now, SAP Cloud
Platform as the platform, as
a service offering from SAP,
combined with the latest
technologies from Google,
to extend those core business
processes, while still keeping
the integrity while customers
build those innovations.
And this platform now
runs on Google Cloud.
So that's a game changer for our
customers to build innovation.
PAUL YOUNG: It's a
really big conversation.
I mean, it's fascinating
actually, recently,
how we've seen a huge
uptake in demand.
Whereas customers start
to plan the [INAUDIBLE]
journeys, and start to
bring [INAUDIBLE] over.
It's not just, hey, you
know, lift and shift, right?
It's not just pick
it up and drop it.
They want to improve.
They want to enhance.
They want--
ISABELL PETZELT: Exactly.
PAUL YOUNG: --to do more.
And Cloud Platform is how
you unlock that, right?
And again, the objective is
to make it run here, hopefully
better than anywhere.
ISABELL PETZELT: Exactly.
PAUL YOUNG: --to allow that.
So to that subject,
what happens then?
So customer comes
here, they have SAP
running inside Google Cloud.
They have Google
Cloud [INAUDIBLE]..
They have Cloud Platform.
What does that do to unlock
the intelligent enterprise?
ISABELL PETZELT: Right.
Right.
For that, you need to look at
how SAP delivers innovation,
or how we deliver
innovation to our customers.
On the one hand side,
in the digital core,
we update that
once, twice a year.
And our cloud applications--
for the different [? LOBs, ?]
we deliver innovations
about once a quarter.
So any customer gets
that functionality.
So they do not really
differentiate themselves
through those
packaged applications.
So that is probably also not
the speed that customers really
desire when they want to build
those competitive, disruptive
new business models
because they really
want to innovate rapidly.
They need iteration.
Sometimes, things
work, don't work.
So they need that
flexibility on a platform
to really reinvent their
enterprise processes
at their own pace
and really build
those differentiating
sets of functionality
on top of their packaged apps.
And that is really key
for the partnership-- what
we bring together
to those customers
because we deliver
that innovations on two
level-- on the one hand side
on the infrastructure level
by bringing technologies
to run enterprise
applications from SAP on
containers with Kubernetes,
Knative, bring them really to
enterprise readiness and scale;
and on the other hand side,
on the service level, where we
allow customers to seamlessly
consume infrastructure services
from Google-- be it
machine learning, be it
artificial intelligence,
natural language processing,
and really infuse that into
our core business processes.
Think about the--
we just --released
those event triggers function
as a service for our latest
digital course, S/4HANA.
To give you an
example, I'm German.
I love cars.
And I go now out of
the Google parking lot,
and I take a nice picture
from whatever car--
we are not making
any promotions here--
and post it on my Twitter
feed because it's a cool car.
Then actually what the car
companies are doing today,
they're scanning the social
feeds using image recognition
to detect their cars,
who has posted what
about that car on the web.
And they realize, woo!
This guy wants to-- is
interested or likes my car.
Why don't I sent
him an offer where
he can configure his car,
where he can basically
submit an order.
And ultimately, I
Then throughout the
production process,
which takes a few weeks and
is running on core solid SAP
systems producing hundreds
and thousands of cars
really at scale, those function
as a service now allow you
that an event gets triggered
when that car enters
the painting facility.
And then a picture is sent
to the customer showing
exactly his car in the
production line, when
the seats get in and so on.
So that keeps the
customer engaged
with the entire process.
And this is not happening--
or you should not
do that in your
core applications,
because you don't
want to touch that.
You have to produce
those 200,000 cars.
This is now what you can really
develop on the platform using
services, image recognition
and so on, from Google,
to really build that the
special functionality
without disrupting the core.
So it's no longer
about, let's say,
pure outcomes and processes.
It is really about
redefining the innovation
cycle in your company by quickly
building those innovations
on top of a stable core.
PAUL YOUNG: Very cool.
I think it also ties in-- if we
look back at the conversation,
you did mention
Kubernetes and Knative.
And that's really cool.
But also, if you look
at the investment
we're making in
virtual machines--
so that conversation that
says, hey, I have an idea.
And I want to develop
that really quickly
in Cloud Platform.
I know I want to test it.
So in history, if
you have a giant--
you have a like, 18-terabyte
production system
running inside HANA
where you've got to keep
a spare 18-terabyte box around.
Or you're going to try
and run on top of QA.
And how do you manage
all of that stuff?
As opposed to our world
where you can literally
provision that
server in 30 seconds,
take a replica of production,
take a replica of [INAUDIBLE],,
build the entire
test environment
you need, pay for
it by the second.
If it works, off the production.
If it doesn't work,
back to revision.
Just again, the combination
of SAP and Google Cloud just
unlocks potential
that just isn't--
everyone's dreamed of this.
No one's been able
to achieve it so far.
That point where I can just
spin up copies of production,
run testing, drop them again,
unlocks just massive potential.
The future looks really
cool, I have to say.
That's my opinion.
But I'm biased.
So wrapping it up, what do
customers take away from this?
What's the call to action here?
ISABELL PETZELT: Right.
Because customers, to be clear,
they're making really big bets.
Moving into the cloud, it causes
a whole new set of questions,
because especially
in the enterprise,
they are moving their holy
grail, their core business
applications into the cloud,
and they're really infusing
cutting-edge technologies into
their core processes, which
can be a nightmare, or
a customer really scared
to move that move.
And that is exactly
why customers
need partners they can trust.
They need partners that
understand the enterprise.
And they need partners
that can grow with them.
And that's exactly the
reason for this partnership--
why SAP and Google
came together--
because only together we can
make sure to have our customers
move with confidence
into the cloud
to allow them to rapidly
innovate and experiment
without risk, building
those new functionalities,
leveraging those new
cutting-edge technologies,
while still running
a stable core.
And that is what customers want.
They want to innovate fast.
They want to be agile.
They want to build all of
that on a trusted platform
to evolve their business.
And that is exactly what we
together can deliver them.
PAUL YOUNG: I think
it's really fascinating.
I did a recording for a
partner recently where
I said if you look,
especially right now,
the customers are
looking to [INAUDIBLE]
and do everything else.
A lot of this is--
it's a commitment
almost like a marriage.
You're making a
long-term commitment.
And so you have to
trust and you have
to believe in everyone in it.
And you have to believe
that it gets you
what you want in the end.
I think it's again, the brand
of SAP, the brand of Google,
what we deliver to our
customers combining this
is something quite remarkable,
especially in this scenario.
Really thank you
for the time today.
Hang around.
I know you're going to
sneak off and answer
some questions in the Q&A.
ISABELL PETZELT: We will.
PAUL YOUNG: And come back
later and we'll take some live.
But really appreciate the time.
Thanks for your time.
Yeah, great game here.
So separately, great for us
to talk about the theory,
but let's make it real.
So what we have at this
point is some content
from Axel Koss at METRO.
So four weeks ago, METRO
stood up at Next London.
I think it was about four weeks.
The weeks all blend together in
my travel schedule right now.
Anyway, recently, METRO
stood up at Next London
and talked about how
they're moving their SAP
environment to Google Cloud.
Amazing project.
This isn't just
again, lift and shift.
There are a hundred SAP systems.
He'll tell you himself that
they tend to consolidate down
to one S4 system.
That's a pretty
significant effort.
And there's reasons why they
chose Google Cloud to do that.
And Google Cloud
does the platform.
And I'll let Axel tell
you what those are.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AXEL KOSS: I'm Axel Koss from
METRONOM, METRONOM with a tech
company of METRO.
METRO is one of the biggest
B2B wholesale worldwide.
We have business in 35
countries, 150,000 colleagues,
and 21 million customers.
Our goal means METRO
goal is very clear
to bring the food
and hospitality
sector on a new level by
providing digital solutions
for their business.
The challenges are coming from
different kinds of stakeholder,
internal as well external.
If I have a look on first
on the internal stakeholder,
for example, the
accounting departments,
they would like to close their
books much faster as they
are able to do it today.
On the other side,
controlling would
like to get most likely
real-time insight
into our figures to
make the right proposals
for the management to make the
right decisions afterwards.
And then we are coming to
the external stakeholder.
For example, our
investors, they would
like to get much
better understanding
of our businesses.
And the most important
topic is here for sure,
our B2B wholesale customer.
They are asking for more
and more digital services,
for sure, most likely
in the e-commerce area.
But nevertheless, they are also
asking for much more services
in the finance area.
Here, we already provide
some services like invoice.
To make this happen,
we were searching
for the right infrastructure
and the right ERP system.
We found them with SAP S/4HANA
and Google Cloud Platform.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
First of all, I would like
to mention that we already
have business on Google
Cloud Platform, most likely
in the e-commerce
I mentioned before.
This is an important part of
our omni-channel strategy.
Nevertheless, we spoke
with a Google [INAUDIBLE]
who are involved already
in the e-commerce area,
but also we discussed this topic
with our colleagues by Google.
Based on this, we really
decided to make this move.
I really would like to point
out that from day one on we
were at a very good partnership.
That means for me at least,
we are equal partners.
We are open minded and
we are very focused
to make things happen.
For sure upfront, we had
also a look on the market
to look for other alternatives.
But nevertheless, I really would
like to make the same decision
today once again.
First of all, allow me to
expand what consultation here
means for METRONOM.
This means we, SAP,
Google, and METRONOM
joined forces to realize
our key objective,
to streamline our
SAP finance landscape
from around 100 to 1 system.
Sound ambitious?
Yes!
You are completely right, but
nevertheless, this is our goal.
To make this happen, we were
using first Google Cloud
Platform.
Second, SAP 4/HANA finance
as our core system running
on Google Cloud Platform.
C, SAP Cloud Platform if we
need any kind of developments,
also running on Google Cloud.
What we can see so far, it's
really working as planned.
And if you open such
boxes, you get rid
of all effect in your teams.
Why?
You see a lot of
different opportunities
you can use in the
cloud services.
But stay focused, otherwise,
it can really happen that you
cannot see the
wood for the trees.
We use our objective
and key result process.
That means the outcome was
a clear action item plan.
Based on this,
everybody in the teams
know exactly what to be done.
We defined it so clear
because SAP S/4HANA,
in combination with
Google Cloud Platform
and SAP Cloud Platform give
us as I mentioned already,
a lot of different
opportunities.
But coming back to our
team's key to success
is change management.
Why?
Keep in mind,
everybody has to work
in the future with
SAP4/HANA in the teams.
They are working on a
complete new infrastructure,
and they see a lot
of opportunities
in respect of cloud services.
This is at least for us
in the IT, but as well
in the business,
a big challenge.
Everybody is highly
engaged and everybody
is seeing a clear
advantage of this journey.
Very clear, go out and try it.
Build up your own environment
on Google Cloud Platform
and SAP Cloud Platform.
Define your own user stories
you would like to start with.
I wish you good luck by this.
PAUL YOUNG: So thanks to
Axel for the discussion.
Really appreciate having
METRO as a customer.
I really appreciate them
contributing to this.
And he continues to contribute.
He's live in the Q&A
right now, if you
want to ask him questions.
And please do.
Always the best input
when I was a customer
came from other customers,
and today is no exception.
So with that, my
task of the day is
to introduce you to why we think
running SAP in Google Cloud
is better than anywhere else,
what we're doing in order
to try and make it the best
place to run SAP in the cloud.
So let's start with one slide,
my favorite slide of them all.
This slide basically
is describing to you
the SAP HANA virtual
machines we have available.
And that part of
this conversation
where I see virtual machine
is the most important.
Everybody else in this market
is still largely bare metal.
No one else has a
virtual machine server
above 6 terabytes.
That roadmap says we will
have virtual machines of 12
and 18 terabytes in next year.
We already have, in the light
green box that we'll come back
to, a 7 terabyte VM available
to customers to demonstrate
that it's possible.
That becomes really important
in this conversation,
because if you go back in
history, from launch of R3,
there has been a way that
customers procure and buy
the equipment that
they run SAP on.
Back in the day, this
took a quick sizer
that's still used where
the customers come through,
and as they want
to roll a project,
they have to estimate forwards
what their largest hour will
be in the next three years.
So let's say you're a retailer.
That's not hard to guess.
That's probably 8:00 AM Black
Friday in 2022 at this point,
after deployment.
Good luck, however guessing
what that deployment, what
that sizing is.
And it ultimately is a guess.
There is a point where
you can size to a point,
but then you have
to estimate growth,
you have to estimate
change in software.
And so customers tend to buy
a huge amount of equipment,
and hope that three years
from now they're sized to fit.
And if they don't buy enough,
they have a huge problem,
because they basically have
to trash what they have
and buy again.
If they buy too little, or
actually if they buy too much,
then they've just wasted money.
And no one wants to waste money.
And so the adult answer to
that is not to do that, right?
Because we really can't
predict the future.
Three years from now
is a long time away.
And how are we going to get
to that number predictably?
We're not.
We never have.
It's always been a guess.
I think the challenge for me
is as we migrated to the cloud
and as cloud providers came
online, a lot of them just
replicated that hardware
model directly in the cloud.
So they came along
and they said you
have do a three-year sizing.
You have to tell me how big
you're going to be three years.
You have to sign a
three-year contract.
That's not what the cloud
is supposed to be about.
That's not how this
is supposed to work.
And so at Google Cloud we've
approached SAP radically
differently.
We build our own servers.
We build our own
virtual machines.
We build them from scratch.
And we do that for a reason.
And the reason is exactly
this, that you fundamentally,
when you come to
us, I don't need
to know how big you're
going to be in three years,
because you don't really
know how big you're
going to be three years.
I just need to know
how big you are now.
You can deploy in
that equipment.
And then as you get
bigger, as you grow,
as you change over time,
you have the ability just
to step up through that
rank, because they're all
reconfigurable.
What that does is that allows me
to take a lot of the risk that
exists in your current
environment in sizing
and provisioning,
a lot of things
that prevent you going forwards
because you have to try and get
to a three-year scope that's
relatively fixed and the sizing
is relatively fixed.
I allow you to take all of
that and put it to the side.
And what you're left with
is an environment where
you can deploy at the size you
are now and grow at the speed
you want to grow at.
No one has done that before.
And that unlocks huge
amounts of potential
in your SAP environment as you
grow and you want to change.
So couple with that a couple
of things on this conversation.
So first of all
right now, there's
the 4-terabyte HANA
instance, the ultramem-160.
That's available
to all customers.
Also available in scale out.
That's been available since
June, doing incredibly well.
This box here is
really interesting.
The 7-terabyte HANA server,
that is the Optane server.
So that's the first Cascade
Lake server in the cloud.
That's the first Optane
memory server in the cloud.
It's an amazing box.
SAP published it's own
statistics where that HANA
server boots 12 times faster
than any HANA server that's
come before it.
Uptime matters in this
world, especially in SAP.
If your entire
business, if your retail
stores, if your factories,
if your manufacturer,
buyers, whatever they are, if
they require SAP to be online,
uptime matters.
And that server
boots 12 times faster
when you have to patch
it and restart it.
That's a really big deal.
In term, we haven't published
any performance tasks for it
yet.
But it's the first Cascade
Lake server in the cloud.
We're making huge
investments to get
to be the highest performing,
the most reliable environment
we can get it to be, in order
to deliver that outcome to you
as a customer.
Likewise, the 12 and the
18 are in engineering
to be available next year.
And again, available on
30-second provisioning
globally.
So this is not I tell you I
need an 18-terabyte server
for production, and one for high
availability, and one for QA,
and one for test.
And I pay upfront for them,
and they get delivered to me
in 12 weeks, and I'm
stuck with those servers
for the next three years.
All of this fleet is available
at 30-second provisioning
globally.
That ability to just click on
a button and start a server
and run it unlocks a huge
amount of potential in SAP world
that we've never seen before.
So that on its own
is interesting.
But we're not stopping there.
The other part I'll give
you is a Google tool
called live migration.
So again, if uptime matters
to you, then what's the best
we can do in keeping SAP
servers up as long as possible?
So one of the
challenges is patching.
So earlier in the
year, obviously, there
was a little round
of Intel patches
that came out for security.
Every other provider
on the planet,
when that press release
went out on a Tuesday,
informed all of their
customers that they
had 72 hours to take
an unscheduled outage
and patch the systems.
Now in the world of SAP,
that's not a simple task.
It's not just shutting
down a single server,
patching it, and
bringing it back again.
You have giant clusters
in environments
of servers that are
all interconnected,
where they all have
to be shut down
and they all have to
be patched and they all
have to be restarted.
And you can lose hours
and hours of work.
And it's not insignificant
amounts of money.
We had a customer we talked to
recently here, a $10 billion
manufacturer.
And the answer is
the manufacturing
plants can't run if the servers
are not online from SAP.
So literally, the point where
you get a patch through that
says you have to patch this
within the next 72 hours.
You're not going to take an
unscheduled outage, which
is going to result in three
or four hours of downtime
where the entire
company has to shut down
while it's being patched.
In this case $10 billion
a year manufacturer,
it's a million dollars an hour.
An unscheduled patch is going
to cost them $4 million straight
away.
So there has to be a better way.
There has to be a way
to solve this problem.
And Google has a way
to solve that problem.
We have a tool called
live migration.
Again, all of our
servers are VM.
So what happens
ultimately is the point
where a patch is
released, you don't
have to shut down your servers.
You don't have to
do anything at all.
If you leave a flag
on it in the VM that
says Google is allowed to
patch them, what happens
is we will create a
second parallel server
to the same configuration
of the first.
We'll pre-patch it with
the patches that required.
We'll sync the server
across while it still runs.
And we'll transition
you to the patch server
while the systems are
fully operational.
Zero downtime.
And so again, you go back to
the customer, that's $4 million
saved every time
there's a patch.
That's a huge amount of money.
We currently run over 3,000
SAP systems at Google Cloud.
Every single one of them on
the last round of patching
went through this
process, no issues.
Just do the math on
the amount of money
we saved our customers that run,
and the amount of disruption
we took out of the world--
unique to Google Cloud.
And it's a really,
really big deal.
And it's a really big
deal now, in terms
of what it can save you.
It's a much bigger deal
as a representation
of the engineering
work we're doing
to not just be another place
to run SAP but to be a better
place to run SAP.
Couple with that,
let's come back
to the theme of do I really
know what the future looks like?
Do I really know what I need?
So again, at this point,
pretty much all everyone else
in this marketplace is currently
requiring you to contract
the specific sizes of servers.
So you come in and
say, look, I need--
I think three years
from now I'm going
to need a 12-terabyte server.
Then you have to procure right
now a 12-terabyte server.
So if in the meantime, you
need six 2-terabyte servers
to get to the
12-terabyte server,
you've got to contract for
all of that fundamentally.
There's ways around that,
but generally, you're
going to contract for
more than you need.
And you're locked into
what you would give.
What Google Cloud
does is different.
Because they're all
VM-based, because we
engineer our own
servers, you don't have
to commit to specific sizes.
You commit to a capacity.
And that's what you're
looking at here.
At some point, I really do
need to get a shot of the GUI.
And so the command line-- but
if your command line based,
you'll like this.
Basically it's a command
line where what we're doing
is we're committing to 50,360
gigabytes of HANA memory inside
Europe West 3.
Once you've committed
to that, we'll
bill you for it monthly as you
consume it and use it, however,
you can configure it however
you want it to be configured.
So let's say you need
12-terabytes as an example.
You can start with 12 ones.
You can move to six
ones and three twos.
You can move to three fours.
You can configure it however you
want to configure that as you
go and as your project changes.
Never been done before.
But what it does is it unlocks
you from that false challenge
you've had in the
past of having to know
what size you'll be three years,
and you carrying all the risk.
Now you have the
absolute flexibility
to configure and
move your commitments
as you need them in order to
deliver against a world that's
very hard to predict.
And again, that's a huge risk
that you take as a SAP customer
that you no longer have to take.
We will carry that for you.
We'll help you manage that risk.
Really, really big deal.
And same, we get a
lot of conversation
for instance, with
retailers, as an example,
where they have six, eight
busy weeks in a year.
And so right now
what they have to do
is commit to the
hardware they're
going to need for a single
hour three years from now,
whereas instead they
can commit to what
they need every day to run.
And then they can actually
just buy the excess capacity
that they need for those
six weeks every year.
It's a vastly more
efficient way to run SAP.
It's a vastly more cost
effective way to run SAP.
And it unlocks huge potential.
Again, we talked
about this earlier
with the SAP Cloud
Platform scenario.
But if you need a
copy of production,
you need a copy of QA
in order to run a test,
you don't have to have
a box laying around
to do that you don't run.
You just snap up a
copy in 30 seconds,
consume it from your commit,
if you have availability.
If you don't, you pay
for it by the second.
It's there.
It works.
It runs.
And then when you're done
with it, drop it again.
Flexibility has never
been achieved before.
And it will change
how SAP is run.
And however, it's
new to the market.
And it will take time for
people to understand it.
But once they understand it--
I think you see from
METRO, customers
are starting to
understand that--
it will make a huge difference.
It will change how SAP is run.
But that's never enough.
As I said before,
I was a customer.
This is not enough just to have
hardware available on demand
and everything else.
You got to be able to do more.
Generally, the
upgrade to S4 is fine.
But generally you always want
to have a better business
outcome, not just a
technical upgrade achieved.
So again, Google
stepped in here in order
to try and help you get to
a better business outcome.
So just one example of that.
I'll give you a couple,
but one example of that
is SAP HANA with BigQuery.
So March 20 of this year,
we announced integration
with HANA and BigQuery.
Really big deal.
So inside HANA--
so for those of you
who don't know what BigQuery
is, if your SAP customers,
you're not that aware of Google.
BigQuery is our data warehousing
in the cloud solution,
for want of a better answer.
Can handle petabyte levels
of data at insane performance
levels.
So you can take huge amounts
of data and put it in BigQuery
and do analysis.
So that's great.
However you want to put it
to a practical use case.
So again, without resorting
always to retail examples,
right now, we have a
very, very large retailer
who is a customer
of SAP with HANA
and a customer of
Google with BigQuery.
So the SAP data is streaming
in live from the retail stores
inside HANA.
All the other data
that they have
is sitting inside
Google BigQuery.
What we released is the
smart data access connector,
technically what SAP released,
is a smart data access
connector for BigQuery.
When you log into SAP HANA,
you can see the data model
for SAP HANA and you can see the
data model for Google BigQuery.
You can join both data
sets together in a query,
and execute a query
directly in real time
and get a real-time result back
from both of those analysis
tools.
So incredibly simple for
the end user to work with.
But what it does is it unlocks
tremendous opportunities here.
So one more example
in the retail space.
But we will load cloud
for marketing data
into Google BigQuery for you.
So I know itemized data
sets that you're currently
running advertising campaigns,
[INAUDIBLE] Google BigQuery.
Inside SAP HANA, we
have real-time inventory
in the stores.
And at the simplest level,
we can join both together
and come back and
say, hey, you know
you are advertising
product in this region
that you don't actually have
available at the retail store?
We think you should move to a
different advertising strategy.
That's a simple example.
As a more complicated
example, we
have a retailer recently
who got on stage
and talked about how we've
done some incredibly cool work
for them where we're
actually scanning fashion
images in magazines
and from other sources,
determining colors and
styles that they can see,
that the image analysis tools
can see in the magazine,
and then going back to SAP and
joining that data up into SAP
and saying what do we have
at the retail store that's
in this color palette,
that's in the style match
because these are
things that we believe
people will come in and buy.
And that's what
we should promote.
That's what we should
maintain pricing on.
Huge opportunities
here from being
able to join the SAP tooling
with the native cloud tooling
that Google Cloud
has, and the data
sets that Google
Cloud has in order
to get to a far better
result. And again, that's
our value here.
This isn't just hey,
here's another place
to run SAP in the cloud.
This is how do we deliver
something much more to you?
Or how we help you get much
more value from your SAP asset
and get to the business result
and the business outcome
you want to get to?
Lastly, one of my
favorite things, robotics.
So at TechEd Barcelona
and TechEd Las Vegas,
we had one of these
things on the floor.
It's a MiR Lifter Shifter.
So we don't own MiR.
It's a private company.
It's independent of
us, I should say.
But what we do is we attempt
to make MiR better and better
for our customers.
So contained within
the MiR robot,
there's a communications
package that
talks back to Google Cloud.
So whereas right
now you may want
to automate your
warehousing as example.
If you may want to automate part
of your distribution network.
And you want to have robotics.
That's hard.
By the time you pick
a robotics provider,
you buy the networking,
you wire it all up,
you try and integrate
that back to SAP
to get maximum efficiency, that
is a huge consulting project.
And a lot of technical work with
networking and everything else.
With a cloud
package from Google,
what it will do basically
is MiR will automatically
connect to Google Cloud.
And what we're working
on is basically
that inside SAP S/4HANA,
you register the robots
that you have, they
automatically connect across.
And then all you do is issue a
goods movement inside S/4HANA
And the robot will automatically
dispatch itself off,
grab the shelving or grab
the package that you want,
and bring it back to the person
that you need at your packing
station to do the packing.
That's far beyond
again, just running
SAP on someone else's servers.
This is really working
towards the future.
We all understand that
robotics are coming.
To be able to do it
that easily and to be
able to improve your business
at that level of efficiency,
is something that makes
us radically different.
And again, that's
part of the work
we're doing with SAP
to deliver something
far beyond just the same
SAP running somewhere else.
So that bit's cool, right?
Being able to run SAP or
integrate your robotic package
back to SAP and have it go
grab things for you is cool.
Let's go one more, however.
This is Google.
We don't do think small.
So embedded in the
robot is a lens package.
As it drives around your
distribution center,
it can read the shelves.
It can see what's on them.
It can identify what's there.
What you're seeing as the
graphic comes around here
is it will identify boxes
that are sitting on the shelf.
And then it will identify
individual boxes.
And it can read barcodes
and it can read text.
And it can tell you how
much inventory there
is in any given location.
And it can communicate
that back to SAP.
So just picture that world.
You have a set of robots you
drop in your distribution
center.
They start to drive
themselves around.
They map out the distribution
center themselves.
They identify everything
that's inside that distribution
center.
They communicate it back to SAP.
And from there forward,
you have constantly
running live updated
inventory that's sitting
in your distribution center.
And that's just
one small use case.
But it's an incredible
jump forwards and just
a representation of
the sort of things
we're working on with SAP to
give you something that's just
vastly more than anyone's
attempted to do before
or achieved at this level.
So thanks for your time.
That's a very short summary.
If you weren't aware, I can go
on for a long time about this.
And we'll happily come
visit you and go on
for a long time about all the
things we're doing differently.
That's just a really small
snapshot of what we're doing.
Stay tuned for the live Q&A.
We'll be back in less than a
minute to answer some of the
questions you've submitted.
Welcome back.
We're still taking
questions in the Q&A chat.
But we decided to
take a couple out
here just to answer them live.
Isabell rejoins me.
Thank you one more time.
So quickly, question number one.
How do you bridge from the work
the team is doing with ABAP, as
an example, into the cloud?
ISABELL PETZELT: Right.
That is exactly a
fundamental step
of the journey for our customers
from on premise applications
into the cloud because
they have huge investments
in their on-prem systems that
they've built over decades.
And now they want to have
a move into the cloud
at their own pace.
So that is why they can utilize
SAP Cloud Platform with all
of the latest technologies,
but infusing those technologies
into the core.
And for example, ABAP
developers, which
are a very special species.
And I know a lot of customers
found that very funny
when we announced
that ABAP is now
also available in the cloud.
They can transfer that skill
set to develop on SAP Cloud
Platform, utilizing
those technologies,
and help those developers
really on their journey
into the cloud, securing
the investments,
while at the same
time of course,
they have the choice
to develop on Cloud
Platform in any language.
So it's a whole new
world to recruit also
and leverage different
development skill sets
in the cloud.
PAUL YOUNG: I'm choking
back laughter here,
because I started out
as an ABAP developer.
So after the cameras
are off, I'll
ask you what species
exactly you think I am,
because apparently I
am a special species.
ISABELL PETZELT: Oops.
PAUL YOUNG: But there you go.
Yeah, me and all the other
ABAP developers out there.
The second question
that came in is
we're starting
with dev and test.
Production is a
bigger challenge.
What are you doing to make
production deployments easier?
I guess that one's mine.
ISABELL PETZELT: I think so.
PAUL YOUNG: Good question.
I mean, a lot in this
space we see customers
who it's relatively easy
to pull your credit card
and buy a little dev
box and play with it.
And then move tests across
[INAUDIBLE] scenario.
Production clearly is
a much bigger challenge
around security and
networking and performance,
and all the stuff
that comes with it.
Key focus for us.
I think if all any of
us get is dev and test,
and customers don't
actually move production,
we don't make the final move.
A couple of key things I would
highlight for you, one of which
is automatic configuration.
Tremendous number of customers
we talk to right now,
who frankly have a
production server,
don't have HA, don't have
DR, and run a huge risk.
In our world, that's the sort of
stuff that's hard to configure.
As a DBA network
engineer, you make
you figure that three, four
times in your lifetime.
It's really easy to do wrong
and then have huge problems.
So one of those
examples really quickly
is we have completely automated
provisioning for the VM.
So when you provision your SAP
system in, you don't just say,
hey, I want an SAP system and
I want an HA and I want a DR.
And I wonder why I
pull the network ports.
I'm going to manage all of the
configuration on the replicas.
Completely automate provision.
Pick a primary site,
an HA site, a DR site.
Completely automated
provisioning,
which allows us to get
to, with confidence,
get to roll out of production
workloads in Google Cloud.
The other one I'll add quickly
as we announced at TechEd Vegas
is we're the first provider
to have back end integration.
Incredibly cool if you're
backing up your SAP
environments for
production purposes,
instead of what currently
happens where you take a disk
snapshot, and you have to
copy it to some other storage.
And you're maybe trying to
replicate it at other places
around the world where you're
responsible for copying files
and hoping they
don't get corrupted
and everything along the way.
Basically back end
backs up a blob storage
of your HANA instance.
You can replicate
it multiple places
around the world automatically
using Google Cloud.
And then we can
recover that back
into a fully functioning
copy of your system
in the event of an outage or
something happening typically
in under an hour.
That sort of stuff
allows us to try again--
the comparison isn't just can
I run what I have in the cloud?
The comparison is, wait.
If I have fully automated
provisioning, I have HA,
I have DR, I have
back end integration.
I have all of that stuff, I have
a provably better environment.
And so we invest at a
lot of different levels.
We've talked about this
already, from all the way
up in the AI and ML to down
at the street operation.
All of it has that purpose
of making this the best
place you could
possibly run SAP,
and dealing with real problems
that real customers have.
Isabell, once again,
thanks for the time.
I think we're out of time here.
ISABELL PETZELT:
Thank you, Paul.
PAUL YOUNG: I think
we maybe past time
based on the signals I get.
But anyway, look,
that's all for today.
Really appreciate you
spending the time with us,
and participating
in the webinar.
Separately, just a couple
of highlights for you.
Again, if you want more
information about Google
Clouds, cloud.google.com/sap.
Intelligent Enterprise is at
sap.com/intelligent-enterprise.
And then if you want more
information on METRO,
there's a short link
here that I'm not even
going to try to read.
But you can click on and/or type
in and learn more about METRO.
Really appreciate your time.
We'll be back with another
conversation about SAP soon.
And in the meantime,
please tune in next Tuesday
for the next Cloud
OnAir session.
Thank you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]